14 years is a long time in the video
game industry yet it still doesn't feel
like quite long enough for EA's Dead
Space the original 2008 game is a modern
classic that holds up exceedingly well
by today's standards there's very little
that feels dated about its design and
the Strategic dismemberment that forms
the basis of its combat still offers a
unique and gory throw that is yet to be
replicated this remakes leap in
graphical Fidelity breathes new life
into its stifling horror but public
discourse has been centered on whether
it really needs to exist in the first
place that might be a cynical viewpoint
but it's no less valid and after
reaching the end credits myself I'm
still not entirely convinced it needs to
either yet I'm extremely happy it does
remaking dead space in 2023 may not feel
especially necessary but EA Motif has
crafted a game that manages to improve
upon its excellent progenitor in a
variety of ways even if it's only
marginally so
foreign
these improvements begin with its story
which has been expanded via a number of
alterations to both his characters and
storytelling the basic beats that make
up the original game's narrative remain
intact starting with your fateful
arrival on the USG ishimura after
responding to a distress signal you find
the hulking Planet cracker class ship
flowing lifelessly above the planet of
Ages 7. once on board things take a
familiar sharp turned downhill but now
one silent protagonist Isaac Clarke has
been given a voice to react
appropriately what the [__] these things
once I saw
some of them were wearing a shimmery
uniforms they're the crew how the hell
can they be the crew I'm generally not a
fan of Silent protagonists although
there's always a danger of vocal
characters being overly chatty
especially in a horror game where
atmosphere and tension are so delicate
thankfully that's not the case here and
Isaac's Newfound agency makes him feel
less like a simple tool to be ordered
around actor gonna write reprises the
role after bringing Isaac to life in
dead space's sequels so there's a level
of continuity here that's also reflected
in other aspects of the remake's design
much of the script has been Rewritten to
accommodate Isaac's speech and the tail
it weaves is still engaging the Church
of unitology a cultish religious sect
that plays a significant role in the
Dead Space Universe is much more
prominent this time around especially
early on characters mention the infamous
Church in a way that feels natural
discussing the sect before they're aware
of how substantial its impact will be on
future events
that marker
that's the symbol of the Church of
unitology he didn't take you for a
Believer Isaac my mother was Kendra
Daniels one of Isaac's colleagues and
your main point of contact throughout
the game has also been Rewritten in a
manner that elevates the Remake
previously she was prickly and leaned
into some needlessly antagonistic
Behavior but she's now been transformed
into an empathetic character which pays
off down the line in a more effective
way than before structurally the vast
majority of the Remake is identical to
the original game from The Hectic Dash
to the elevator that follows the initial
reveal of the zombie-like Necromorphs to
the vital task of disabling all of the
wheezers that are poisoning the air on
the Hydroponics deck there are a few
small level design changes sprinkled
throughout along with some notable
gameplay improvements for starters the
zero gravity sequences now let you leap
from the ground and use your suits
thrusters to freely move around each
area rather than rigidly hopping from
one surface to another being able to
essentially fly through these segments
makes them much more interesting than
they were before as you're forced to
deal with enemies that can attack from
any angle while orienting yourself to
solve various puzzles some of these
sections like the ishimura's hangar have
also expanded in scope deviating from
the design of the ship's energy to give
you a bit more freedom to explore others
like the ads Canon repair job has been
completely redesigned to ramp up the
tension shifting from a stale turret
Shooting Gallery to a treacherous
spacewalk and this carries over into
your fights against the Leviathan as
well if you've played Dead Space 2
before the freedom of movement in the
redesigned 0g segments will feel
instantly familiar and this is a
consistent theme throughout this remake
the addition of special upgrades for
each weapon in Isaac's arsenal of mining
tools has also carried over from the
2011 sequel you can attach a mod to the
plasma cutter that causes the ammunition
to set a light anything you shoot
dealing scolding burn damage over time
while another lets you use the disc
Ripper to Ricochet saw blades that slice
through multiple enemies these mods are
scattered throughout the ishimura so
you're rewarded for searching every nook
and cranny of the desolate mining vessel
a new security clearance system
initially locks you out of certain rooms
and lockers though but you'll gradually
unlock higher clearance levels as you
progress through the story this system
feels like it was added in service of
the inclusion of bespoke side quests
which tasks you with backtracking to
previously explored areas of the ship
having a reason to go back makes
revisiting what were once locked doors
feel organic and the Now seamless travel
between each part of the ship makes it
feel like a genuine place but the side
quests themselves aren't particularly
interesting from a gameplay perspective
enemies occasionally crop up to provide
an obstacle along familiar routes but
you can often backtrack in relative
safety and these quests essentially boil
down to picking up an item or activating
a previously recorded message attaining
more background information on what
happened aboard the ishimura before
everything went to hell is a narrative
treat at least particularly if you're
invested in the series's law but it's a
shame these side quests aren't a little
more involved unlike the aforementioned
upgrades the primary fire modes for each
weapon have largely remained the same as
in the original game however a few of
Isaac's repurposed Firearms have the
entirely new secondary functions the
pulse rifle's alternate fire was
formerly only really useful when
completely surrounded by enemies letting
you hunker down to envelop yourself in a
hail of bullets this took a hefty toll
on your ammunition and there were very
few opportunities to use it without it
feeling like a waste for the Remake
Isaac's pulse rifle now comes equipped
with a dual purpose proxim in mind that
functions as either a trap or a
makeshift grenade launcher I found
myself using this and the secondary fire
modes on other weapons more often than I
did in the original Dead Space largely
because they introduce an additional
layer of strategy to each encounter with
the ship's infestation of Necromorphs
the flamethrower's new secondary fire
mode is another good example providing
you with the option to shoot a wall of
flame that can separate enemies by
coordinating them off from one another
with a fiery Blaze out of all the
revised weapons however it's the force
gun that stands out amongst the crowd
previously this mid-game weapon was
little more than a tool for pushing
enemies away now it's been redesigned to
unleash a thunderous blast of energy
that rip skin and muscle clean off the
bone it's a delightfully gruesome weapon
that makes Exquisite use of the remake's
new peeling system which looks as gross
as it sounds
foreign
the remakes overhauled visuals are
phenomenal across the board bringing the
ishimura's suffocatingly Grim battles to
life with a disgusting Sheen it's an
iconic location for a reason and the
visual upgrade and share attention to
detail contribute to it feeling more
lived in than ever that's true whether
it's the abandoned suitcases strewn
across the arrival Lounge the cramped
crew quarters and the Glimpse they offer
into the dreary existence of those
working aboard the ship or the posters
for a product described as carbonated
hard bar providing the only semblance of
color amongst this metal called Toys the
peeling system is one facet of the
remakes improved graphical Fidelity and
it has a delightful impact on each
combat encounter it ensures that skin
fat and muscle layers are ripped off
enemies with each successive wound
making the exposed bones vulnerable to
snapping in half from a well-placed
round or two the green light running up
the spine of Isaac's suit is a visual
indicator of his health and this makes
the necromorph's own bodies a reminder
of theirs that spaces combat still feels
somewhat fresh because of the way it
foregoes genre conventions where the
headshot is King Necromorphs can only be
killed by slicing off their limbs and it
remains incredibly satisfying using
weapons like their plasma car to lock
them off at the legs before blasting
away at their elongated arms as they
desperately crawl towards you the
peeling system only enhances the
experience for as good as the original
Dead Space was the repetition did set in
during the final couple of hours but the
remakes added strategy and the variety
of tools you're able to play around with
prevent this from happening again
foreign
it's impossible to expect the Dead Space
remake to be as transformative as
something like the Resident Evil 2
remake was the generational leap isn't
as Grand and so much about it feels
inherently familiar to the 2008 original
such is the way EA Motif has weaved its
changes into the Dead Space mold the new
side quest might leave a lot to be
desired but every other addition
contributes to a remake that stays true
to its progenitor while also improving
upon it in a number of ways newcomers
and Hardcore Dead Space fans will get
the most out of the experience but this
is now the quintessential way to play
one of the survival horror genres best
thank you